last we left it felt like Magnus was
putting the pressure he has won the C6
spawn is there a killer blow here
feels really really shaky for black
white can give a check for example
White's Rook can lift up to C8 and okay
the most natural move is a strong one
you need the follow-up of course uh the
engine as we see below the board does
confirm white has only one winning move
this is just a once uh kind of blink and
you miss it opportunity but what's the
follow-up what is it Rook seat your only
move is King 287 how do you finish this
off maybe
Queen on the c2c3 yeah yeah something
like that maybe we show this because uh
it was a blunder from naponishi uh maybe
just ticking his eye off the ball here
looks like Rook to C8 suggested by the
computer is best forcing the black king
to the side of the ward and Simon you
had an idea I think in Queen C2 to force
G6 and once you go G6 to try to get the
queen in on the dart squares so you go
Queen C3 and that seems to force like F6
which is a really
ugly move to play you don't want to play
F6 and
assume there'd be something here I
didn't know what the board and here I
guess white could just step the pawn
forward maybe bring his Rook to C7
instead in the punishi defense with this
creative move Knight to F6 but uh this
is ignored of course taking the Knight
would have lost the white Rook so he
just pushes his Pawn forward in a huge
threat Rook C7 could be a killer yeah I
like that the pawn joins the podium Rook
C7 with the Knight on F6 hanging how do
you fight that he is going for the
counter offense with the move B4 on the
board uh that is why I keep everything
intact because you've got to keep the
Rook defended on C8
to keep this piece yeah under watchful
gaze I'm wondering whether you can trade
off Queens maybe a move like Queen to
cease C7 it feels like going back would
be the wrong direction suddenly black is
going to start hitting you with this
Pawn
and yeah I think quizzes of elimination
and now the problem is after Queen takes
Queen the key is to take back what it's
going to say with the pawn do you take
back with the pawn here the threat is to
jump out the way with your Rook with a
check giving away The Rook but uh
forcing your Pawn through on that on the
next move I think that might be the
Clincher
[Music]
and black would probably have to
sacrifice a beast there with Knight
jumping back to E8 to give that up to
win the C7 Pawn but it shouldn't be
enough you just pick up the knight uh
and having this extra beep on under
control that should be easy Queen C7 on
the board big big trouble for Jana Pam
Nashi uh if not Queen takes E7 can he
find a way to go just Queen but if you
move the Queen the White Queen is
jumping on to d8 with a threat along the
eighth rank yeah I think the publishi
actually when he made that mistake he
calculated four through five moves into
the future but he just stopped one move
too soon I think he missed Queen C7 or
at least underestimated it and Magnus
just saw one move deeper
um that's the kind of stakes at this
level uh often you see enough but if you
take your eye off the ball if you stop
if you don't push your calculation then
sometimes the opponents just see further
and hear this looks like yeah suddenly
Magnus has worked his magic he's really
recovered from that previous game
we'll see throughout the match right
starting from game one getting that the
end game and then creating his chances
and getting big advantage in that one
game two as well pushing for the
majority of the game till that oversight
and now this one fully under control
Queen C7 player yeah she's shaking his
head can't get out of this trade you go
Queen A6 Queen d8 looks like game over
if you trade the queen you just go into
an end game down an entire piece a big
trouble here for Yan
yeah basically yeah it looks really
difficult and uh uh can't I mean I guess
Magnus will spot the Checkmate in this
one as well and this this was the star
move right Queen C7 and yang clearly
missed this move it looked like he he
was getting very good compensation with
his B Pawn and uh it's an easy move to
miss because it kind of seems clumsy
putting the queen uh on the Square but I
I can't see a defense at the moment and
after Queen takes Queen David you
pointed out Pawn takes which is probably
winning maybe Rook takes is also pretty
close to winning you know Queen takes
Queen Rook takes might might be a little
bit cleaner so nepo trying to give his
King uh some some room to breathe here
but that doesn't look like it's gonna I
mean at least the White Knight is pinned
because uh you know if you could start
using the White Knight it'd be tricky
and that does create a threat Pawn G4
don't go into it yeah 28 would be a huge
blunder actually a game changing blunder
full 360. black just plays G4 calls the
bluff this is just one on track the
black king gonna run and it can continue
running and okay Magnus is found a
stronger move he takes the Queens off
the board no more pin along this
diagonal and the Clincher Rook C7 same
idea that you mentioned Simon Brooke
takes Rook allows the pawn to promote no
stopping that and if you don't go for
the trade if you move your Rook then the
problem is Rook takes Pawn is a double
attack a fork on the king and Knight and
if the black king moves then you jump in
with a check defending a rook
simultaneously and there's several ways
to win this position you can just go
ahead and make a new Queen if you want
to be flashy maybe take this Knight and
then give a night Fork but uh yeah I
think this one is game over and okay
he's found a different path for the
black Rook he's holding things together
but Knight E5 has happened anyway and
Magnus wow Knight to G4
what is this
ah King takes night now I guess he wants
to meet by Rook takes
a check yeah there's a Checkmate wow
lovely Rook takes Pawn now looks like
the most natural move took us a while
but look at this the black king finally
caught Magnus does know his checkmates
everyone even in an end game the black
king is about to be caught on the edge
of the board we're seeing this video I
think we're going to see a Checkmate on
the board in this one he missed it in
game two but he's gonna play it out this
one the problem in game two was that
were Queens on the board he was so angry
he missed that Checkmate in the last
game he had to prove to everyone that he
can he can do it and this is this is
quite a beautiful beautiful really
beautiful and if you go G4 there's Rook
F5 as well coming in you really can't
fight it white will end up queening and
that is it